on tue mardi angela merkel a rencontré
les dirigeants des 16 et allemand ils
ont décidé de prolonger le confinement
jusqu'au 14 février ainsi que
d'introduire des mesures plus strictes
notamment il faudra porter des masques
de qualité médicale dans les magasins
les transports entre autres lieux
plusieurs régions allemandes ont
également commencé à mettre en place des
centres de quarantaine forcée pour ceux
qui transgressent de manière répétée les
restrictions sanitaires et les autorités
ont insisté sur le fait qu'il s'agirait
là d'un dernier recours
précédé par des avertissements des
amendes et qu'il reviendrait un tribunal
le qualifier des récidivistes
ces centres existants saxe dans le bade
wurtemberg où schleswig-holstein le
brandebourg et la ville état de berlin
ont déclaré vouloir leur emboîter le pas
le gouvernement de la bavière l'un des
étalements les plus touchés par la
pandémie a dit se réserver le droit de
placer en détention ce qui ne respectent
pas la quarantaine ou refusent de se
mettre en quarantaine la région de hesse
avait déjà créé un tel centre l'année
dernière il avait fermé faute de besoins
plusieurs états ont déclaré ne pas
souhaiter s'engager dans cette voie la
thuringe par exemple affirme ne pas
considérer cette solution pour le moment
mais un certain nombre d'états comme je
les dix ont déjà mis en place ou
s'apprêtent à mettre en place de tels
sommets
il est important de souligner que selon
les sondages la majorité des allemands
acceptent de se plier aux mesures
adoptées
cependant certains signes indiquent que
la limite pour être proche
plus tôt cette semaine avant la réunion
entre angela merkel et les seize
dirigeants des régions allemandes
un sondage indiquait que seuls 28 % des
allemands considérer des mesures plus
strict nécessaire
il s'agit d'une baisse de 21% ce qui
suggère que les allemands ont atteint
leurs limites
particulièrement avec l'idée que des
anciens centres de réfugiés des hôpitaux
sécurisé ou même des centres de
détention pour mineurs par exemple
pourrait à l'avenir accueillir ceux qui
transgressent les règles sanitaires de
manière répétée